coach mcmillan trusts you implicitly he  says you're calling more  more plays for your team what's this  like down the stretch for you knowing  you're in control  of what happens uh it's it's a lot i  mean it's great that i have a coach that  trusts me  and uh trust me that i'm gonna put our  team in the best position to win  and i'm still learning i still have a  lot to learn a lot to get better at  but i feel like right now we're in a  good place and we've got to keep winning  and keep  keep believing in each other  congratulations thanks for stopping  appreciate it  39 points steph he's got five  30-plus point road games in this playoff  109 106. the hawks come back  and shock the sixers now to iron eagle  clippers jazz